it's III 2016 zorion you and I got to
see a pretty cool gameplay walkthrough
of Call of Duty infinite warfare that's
right it is a brand-new never seen
before section of gameplay that we were
treated to now we can't actually show
you guys what we saw ourselves but we
can give you an awesome blow-by-blow
description of all the cool things that
we noticed it what do you think well I
was blown away yeah Escalades it goes
straight into it you're in the streets
and explosions are happening you're
under attack and everything just goes to
hell straight away yeah like your cup
streets are covered in smoke the
citizens are screaming and you have a
robot companion with you right to help
get you through the situation yeah I
think it's really cool it was really
cool I think his name is Ethan you see a
little bit of it in the e3 press
conference of him they there yeah you
kind of like tag team with this
companion robot right I mean yeah
companions not really the right word
like he's like one of your squad he's a
soldier you know and he's like picking
up the citizens and yelling at them like
get to safety or get off the streets
yeah but that was really cool what yeah
like this time around is finally nice to
see like an AI companion I guess or
whatever uh who's friendly who seemed
very like like fun character he seems
genuine to e people up yet get back to
CTU but things get really really heated
from there um like ships come blasting
into the streets they land and of course
you know the fighting starts yeah so
there are other robots that you fight
against as well and you saw you start
pulling out like all these cool weapons
I've never seen before one which I
thought was really cool was like this
mind that had like legs on it a spider
bite a drone ish thing and like the
character would put him like rice would
put him on the ground and then the
spider would just run off and kind of
latched onto the back of an enemy's neck
and blow up that and then it just
incinerate the enemy yeah it was really
terrifying because you hear them
screaming right before the
but yeah super fun to watch yeah if
spiders went scary enough for you then
these mines like might be the worst
night gotta do it the other really cool
gun that I saw was kind of like look
like a scatter kind of shotgun oh so
cool and it had like these points so you
see like multiple like I guess
particularly like the like the points of
where you should write it was almost
like the red a red dot scope attachment
and each it was a hey ya head of the
scattered pellets so he's young and yeah
it was really cool what it did and that
would send her in on an enemy is that
you were targeting after a few seconds
so like it just be like immediately like
you swing over and then the pellets kind
of like realigned to the enemy and you
should and I thought that was really
interesting with it right it I want to
see more of that yeah it would almost
like the pellets would pinpoint on limps
even yeah yeah really cool looking I
mean the weapons are the highlight of
the call of duty series it's always
great to see what kind of new stuff that
they come up with especially since we're
going like into the future speaking of
which this fight goes straight into a
jet and then it just shoots up through
the atmosphere and you fly right into
space yeah I thought if like a game
every game had a pivotal moment that
identified or like what it was I thought
was that moment for me absolutely and it
really was symbolic of the series
rightly we are we're doing it we're off
plant we're exploring the solar system
yet yeah we're punching at an atmosphere
and and that demo it ended on like like
another spaceship exploding it was crazy
like you know though that you were like
in a jet whatever you want to call it
and a ship and just shooting like
everything else that it was just like
wow this is this is it still felt really
cool of duty to me but it was just like
in a different place like that I've
never seen before yeah extremely
cinematic I was it was really fun to
watch and I can only imagine you'll have
a similar experience playing it another
thing I think to take away and this was
I watching the trailer and it's
definitely in there is you it's not too
different from the series but it looks
really interesting you can call in you
know on your armband
a jet like kind of an air support I
utility that he would it look like you
could change the weapons of the jet I'm
not quite sure but he would come in a
few times and just hose down on a
component do anything pointed yes so
Opie yes I was can't wait to see more
than wrong I gave looks sermons I am
unashamedly excited for this game but
that's basically what we saw our call of
duty it's in a warfare for more on that
make sure to check out guess what com